aoc the politician has comments on
bitcoin there is a screenshot that is
circulating the internet where uh she
basically posted on instagram and took
questions and one of the questions was
do you invest in bitcoin aoc's response
was the following because we have access
to sensitive information and upcoming
policy i do not believe members of
congress should hold or trade individual
stocks and i choose not to hold any so i
can remain impartial about policy making
i also extend that to digital assets and
currencies especially because i sit on
financial services committee so the
answer is no because i want to do my job
as ethically and impartially as i can
aoc and i don't agree on a lot of things
i tend to think that uh there are a ton
of bombastic statements a lot of uh
irrational comments but i will give
credit whenever somebody says something
that i think is very rational this in my
opinion is actually a very very
important point which is that
politicians who have any sort of hand
in creating policy who have any
influence over specific industries et
cetera becomes very
weird they use the word weird that they
also would hold assets in those
industries and so ultimately i don't
know how much congress is actually going
to have a hand in influencing policy etc
when it comes to something like
cryptocurrencies that's up for debate
but this specific position around
politicians not being able to hold
individual stocks or assets that can be
impacted by their policy decisions tends
to be something that i think is a pretty
good idea now i don't think we're ever
going to get politicians to agree to
create rules for themselves that are
more restrictive than let's say the
average american obviously they usually
do the opposite they say there's rules
for thee and not for me but i do think
that this is a pretty good point by aoc
now on top of that what i think becomes
really interesting is that whether we
were talking about the media or
politicians they should have to disclose
that they hold us dollars as well if you
are let's say a reporter and you read an
article about cryptocurrencies and you
hold dollars there should be a big fat
disclaimer at the bottom that says this
individual holds majority of their
financial portfolio in dollars
why if you have to do it for bitcoin
would you not do it for dollars same
thing for politicians especially if you
are being negative towards other assets
and you hold something as a store of
value whether you hold treasuries or you
hold dollars or cash like assets then
you should have to disclose that just as
much do we like aoc's point here or do
we think that this is overblown and uh
uh maybe not as much as credit as i'm
giving her i like her point i think it's
actually a very like nice thing for her
to say in the sense of she understands
that if you're kind of regulating this
industry it's tough to be a part of it
um i obviously know the fact that if you
have us dollars and you're regulating
the us dollar by or changing the uh
the value of the currency by printing a
ton more and stuff like that it's really
tough situation but yeah i think it's
funny that you've continuously said that
if you own
real estate and you write about real
estate you should have to disclose that
i don't think you should have to
disclose it yeah i mean i agree i think
this is kind of what uh i would say the
majority of people believe right is that
you should either pay politicians more
so they don't have to worry about this
kind of stuff or you should make them
put in a trust where they don't have
access to be able to make individual
trades people joke about nancy pelosi
all the time but this is the solution to
that right is not owning individual
stocks not using your position of power
not using your position of influence to
trade and make money on these decisions
and i think that she's right i think uh
it's unfortunate that some people are
put in positions where they are accused
of profiting on things off of knowledge
whether they did it on purpose or not uh
it's a tough position for politicians
and i think that this is the way out of
that right is having either someone else
manage your money or not owning
individual stocks or shares of companies
and just doing kind of etfs or mutual
funds or stuff like that when it comes
to digital assets it's a little more
difficult right there are sitting
politicians right now sitting senators
who own bitcoin who have been open about
their ownership of bitcoin and i don't
think that's a bad thing i think that
aoc is probably open to changing her
mind on this i think it's more about
just using education as a tool to get
people to do that the piece that uh is
important here is one disclosures
they're all required to disclose assets
so unless they're either one lying on
the disclosures which would be illegal
there'd be a bunch of ramifications if
they get caught but also two is i think
where people start to get into this like
weird world is uh if you remember during
2020 there was the um uh the public
health crisis that was on the uh kind of
horizon it was coming and there was a
briefing that was done and there were
stock sales that were all happening and
frankly people don't know
who did what and so if you have a
portfolio that's managed by somebody
else did you make a phone call did you
not how did it work like there's always
questions and so i think that generally
uh being able to appeal for the view or
the appearance of not being unethical is
more important than actually are you
unethical or not because people are
unethical for the most part i think
folks either one discover it or two they
get caught right so if you're cheating
on your taxes you end up getting caught
uh two is that there are politicians and
i see people in the comments saying that
uh their names if they're doing weird
stuff people figure it out right and
again maybe they don't get actually
punished which is a whole nother issue
but ultimately that stuff kind of tends
to rise right there are politicians who
seem to be some of the best day traders
in america
how does that happen well you can start
to do your own research on that so i do
think that that stuff is uh important
but in terms of not owning the
individual assets stocks make a lot of
sense when it starts getting into
bitcoin or other types of assets do we
now have politicians who aren't going to
hold other let's say foreign currencies
right do we where do you stop the line
can they not own real estate if they're
actually having some oversight over
housing should they not own their own
home like i think there's some parts
people like okay there's like an
irrational uh extremism to this idea
where maybe you should be allowed to own
your own home right that seems pretty
reasonable uh should you be allowed to
invest in real estate
right and this goes back to i think
we've talked about on the show before uh
there was an entire point uh that
somebody made um around
uh
uh
in new york city what is the l train
right nobody here takes the l right
because we don't take else but the l
train at one point was rumored to get
shut down and so the l train connects
manhattan to brooklyn uh at a certain
point and in brooklyn uh a bunch of the
real estate people started to move out
of that area because they're like oh
they're gonna shut down the l train it's
gonna be very hard for me to get into
the city and so when they did that real
estate prices started to drop right
because there's supply demand so demand
was going down prices started to drop
all of a sudden it was announced that
the l train is not going to be shut down
and instead what they are going to do is
they are going to do the maintenance
while it's running during certain hours
so what happened the real estate prices
exploded again in that area right by the
l train where it got out in brooklyn now
if you had that information and you went
you started to buy a bunch of real
estate a couple of days or a couple of
weeks before it was actually publicly
announced that insider trading a lot of
questions there right and somebody like
matt levine over at bloomberg he wrote
for like multiple days he was writing
about this idea of like what constitutes
actual insider uh trading if you have
public non-material information of a
corporation definitely insider trading
regulators will come after you is that
public non-information uh uh public
material uh information
kind of
but it's not really a
corporation now you're talking about
policy but the policy isn't like a
regulatory policy it's literally are we
going to shut down the subway and you're
making investment decisions on a second
or third order effect gets in a weird
world and so i think that's the type of
stuff that people are like oh that's a
little bit more of a gray area but there
are very specific things that people do
where you're like dude that's like right
there that was super unethical